Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Jacob from
Denver? Jacob from Denver. Welcome to the David
Pakman show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: But.
Okay, John.
Speaker 1: You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Q I just have a question about
hypocrisy. Okay. So I've been following your
channel now for a long time, and it's it's
all over the Internet. It's all over news.
This idea that, you know, someone's being
hypocritical is like, is it even valuable
to point out hypocrisy anymore? Well, politics
or in general, or is it just is it a fallacy?
Speaker 1: It's not a fallacy. No, it's not a
fallacy to point out hypocrisy. It helps us to
get at sort of the root of what elected officials
really care about. Right. Like, for example,
if an official claims to care about the deficit
when a Democrat is president, but not when a
Republican is president, it suggests to us they
don't really care about the deficit. They care
about scoring political points. And then it allows
us to maybe more accurately assess and evaluate
the things that they say. So in that sense, it's
not fallacious. You are getting at a reality,
though, which is not only have Republican elected
officials clearly stopped trying to avoid the
appearance of hypocrisy and double standards,
their voters also don't seem to care. So there
is a question about the utility of us pointing out
right wing hypocrisy when the elected officials
don't care and their voters don't seem to
care. Is it just a waste of time? I think
that that's a perfectly fair question to ask.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I agree. I do. I do feel that
itch. There should be some sort of value behind
it. Yeah, but it's almost like a fatigue at this
point. It's like, how much longer can anybody
stand watching anybody call somebody else a
hypocrite? It just feels so vapid at this point.
Speaker 1: 100%. It does. It shouldn't,
but it does because consistency has been abandoned
even as a goal. And that's really the sad part.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I remember.
Hey, thanks for the call.
Speaker 1: All right. Yep. Jacob from Denver.
Great to hear from you. Let's go next to David
from St Petersburg. Now, is this Saint Petersburg,
Florida, or Saint Petersburg, Russia? Oh, boy.
David from St Petersburg. Welcome to the program.
And last chance for David from Saint Petersburg.
Sadly, we will never know. Was it Russia?
Or was it Florida? Very sad. Very, very sad.